il a été créé le 7 janvier 1971 le
ministère de l'écologie à 50 en cinq
décennies de galère de manque de moyens
mais aussi de démission en baghai je
l'avais dit à l'époque je considérais
que faire au ministère de
l'environnement c'était très difficile
mais qu'il fallait le faire
lui c'est robert poujade le tout premier
ministre de l'environnement en 1971 il
est nommé par le président georges
pompidou en fonction depuis seulement
deux jours robert poujade s'inquiétait
déjà dû faible budget à sa disposition
mon problème ce n'est pas seulement
celui de la bonne volonté qui est
entière c'est celui des moyens qu'il
faudra trouver et dégager et ça ne sera
pas facile
très vite le ministère change de nom
beaucoup de français parce que c'est un
ministère forte où les années passent
les dénominations change sans arrêt et
le manque de moyens se fait toujours
ressentir 1991
même refrain cette fois c'est brice
lalonde à leurs ministres de
l'environnement qui est l'invité de
l'émission l'heure de vérité sur antenne
2 qu'est ce que pèse aujourd'hui
l'environnement dans le budget français
très peu de 1 pour mille à ce manque de
moyens s'ajoute la pression des lobbys
et les divergences politiques
conséquence les ministres se sentent
délaissés et s'enchaînent michel barnier
corinne lepage
dominique voynet en 2001 la ministre de
l'aménagement du territoire et de
l'environnement démissionne après
l'échec de son projet de loi sur l'eau
croit avoir avec beaucoup de vaillance
et de détermination et de constance
engagement défendu mon point de vue ce
sentiment d'abandon
dominique voynet n'est pas la seule à
l'avoir ressenti
c'est aussi le cas de delphine batho en
2013 la ministre de l'ecologie critique
la baisse du budget de son ministère à
la radio c'est vrai que c'est un mauvais
budget et moi je souhaite que dans les
jours qui viennent nous puissions faire
la démonstration qu effectivement la
volonté de faire de la france la nation
de l'excellence environnementale la
transition énergétique ne sont pas des
variables d'ajustement
conséquence de cette prise de parole
critique le président françois hollande
l'a limoges dans la foulée depuis
delphine batho en 2013
ils sont sept à s'être succédé à la tête
du ministère de l'écologie parmi eux
nicolas hulot en 2018 après avoir
dénoncé l' influence des lobbys il
quitte ses fonctions en direct à la
radio
je ne veux plus me mentir je veux pas
donner l'illusion que ma présence au
gouvernement signifie qu'on est à la
hauteur sur ces enjeux là et donc je
prends la décision de quitter le
gouvernement
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui vous êtes
sérieux
oui je suis sérieux
[Musique]